all right put your dancing shoes on
there's a new attraction coming to the
las vegas strip and it's inside the link
bianca holmen has all the details on
disco show
caesars entertainment and spiegel world
announced the future of entertainment
here in las vegas and i hear that if you
love this show the absence you're going
to love a new show coming to the link
the announcement was held at beijing
noodle number nine gazillionaire the
host and emcee of the show absence made
an appearance signifying the expansion
the show is called disco show and it
will premiere at the link over the
course of two years three new
productions will debut across the
country the new show here in las vegas
will take over the sports book at the
link creating a totally new immersive
entertainment destination we are going
to build a theater unlike anything
anyone's seen in the world this is a
theater
that is five walls of led
including the floor the entire floor is
made of led it's going to be the most
extraordinary experience the other shows
will be in atlantic city and new orleans
this is a 75 million dollar investment
for this project and again we hear that
if you love to dance you love donna
summers and this show is for you the
disco show is going to
debut at the end of 2022. bianca holman
live local now